cuál de las siguientes opciones describe
mejor la gráfica de este sistema de
ecuaciones nuestro sistema es igual a
menos 2 x + 3 y 5 y igual a menos 10 x
15 tenemos las opciones dos líneas
idénticas de dos líneas paralelas de dos
genes que se intersectan en un solo
punto y de dos líneas que se intersectan
en sólo dos puntos
no podemos descartar esta última opción
porque dos líneas no se pueden
interceptar en dos puntos esto sólo
ocurre con las curvas
ahora analicemos estas dos ecuaciones
tenemos aquí arriba que es igual a menos
2 x 3 y vemos que aquí abajo tenemos 5 y
bueno vamos a multiplicar esta ecuación
de arriba por 5 veamos
5 porque es 5 g
igual a menos 2x por 5 va a ser
- 10 x
y 3 por 5 es 15 así que eso será más 15
bueno de hecho estamos viendo que esta
ecuación es igual a esta de aquí abajo
al multiplicar ambos lados de la
ecuación por 5 realmente no estoy
cambiando nada de la ecuación la
igualdad se mantiene al hacer esta
multiplicación tenemos que nos da la
misma ecuación de aquí abajo así que son
la misma línea nuestra opción correcta
de respuesta es la opción a dos líneas
idénticas veamos el siguiente problema
39 simplifica 5x al cubo entre 10 x
elevado a la 7
existen muchas formas de simplificar
esto pero para mí la forma más sencilla
de expresarlo así 5
entre 10
x x al cubo
x x al menos 71 / x a la 7 es igual a x
elevado a la menos 7
y como estas dos bases son iguales al
multiplicar las solo tenemos que sumar
los exponentes y aquí simplificó 5 entre
10 lo vivido todo entre 555 es 110 entre
5 es 2 esto es un medio y
como los exponentes 3 menos 7 es igual a
menos 4 esto es igual a un medio por x a
la menos 4
que a su vez es igual a 1 entre 2 por
equis a la cuarta
y está bueno es la opción b aunque no
los estoy mostrando todas las opciones
esto puede resolverlo de otra manera por
ejemplo pude haber dividido el numerador
y el denominador entre 5 y luego dividir
el numerador el numerador de x al cubo
entre x al cubo y también lo mismo aquí
abajo de haber tenido vamos a escribirlo
con otro color
tengo que 5x al cubo entre 10 x a la
séptima aquí
me queda lo mismo 55 es 110 entre 5 es 2
nos queda un medio
y aquí dividir x al cubo entre x al cubo
y x a la séptima entre x al cubo si hago
esto
x al cubo / x al cubo va a ser igual a 1
y si hago esto de x
a la séptima / x al cubo resto los
expone este exponente a este otro y me
va a quedar que es x a la cuarta
así que me queda lo mismo me queda que
esto es igual a 1 entre 2 por equis a la
cuarta
o también pudieron ahorrarse pasos al
observar esto que se está dividiendo con
la misma base la equis y simplemente
simplificar este lado como lo hemos
hecho y restar directamente este
exponente con este para obtener el menos
4 el x elevado al menos 4
todas estas aproximaciones nos llevan a
la misma respuesta a la respuesta
correcta veamos el problema número 40
nos piden desarrollar esto 4x al
cuadrado menos 2 x 8 menos lo que está
entre paréntesis
x cuadrada más 3 x 2 y esto nos piden
que encontremos aquí es igual
esto luce con una simplificación y aquí
debemos darnos cuenta de que hay un
menos en esta parte entonces este menos
se tiene que distribuir con todo lo que
se encuentra aquí dentro del paréntesis
vamos a desarrollar esto queda igual 4x
cuadrada 4x cuadrada menos 2 x más 86
más 8
- esto multiplicado al menos imaginamos
que aquí hay un menos uno menos 1 x cada
uno de estos elementos menos 1 por x al
cuadrado es menos x al cuadrado
al cuadrado menos 1 x 3 x va a ser igual
a menos 3x y menos 1 x menos 2 va a ser
igual a más 2
ahora vamos a agrupar los términos
veamos el término más grande que son las
cuadradas x al cuadrado menos x el
cuadrado de hecho y 4 x al cuadrado
esto es igual 4x cuadrada - x cuadrada
será igual a 3 x cuadrada ahora veamos
los términos que tienen la x solita
menos 2x y menos 3 x menos 2 x menos 3 x
va a ser igual a menos 5 x
y finalmente tenemos nuestros términos
constantes el 8 y el 28 más dos es igual
a 10 este es el resultado de esta
ecuación 3x cuadrada menos 5x más 10 y
esa es la opción de aunque aquí no se
las estoy mostrando veamos el siguiente
problema que es el número 41 la suma de
dos binomios de 5x cuadrada menos 6x si
uno de los binomios es 3x cuadrada menos
dos x cuál será el otro binomio
recordamos que binomio es un polinomio
con dos términos veamos que podemos
hacer aquí vamos a bueno nos dicen que
la suma de dos binomios y este es el
resultado nos dan uno de los binomios
vamos a reescribir los tenemos que el
primer binomio 3x al cuadrado menos 2x
más otro binomio nuestro binomio
misterioso que bueno vemos el resultado
tiene un término en x al cuadrado y otro
en x así que nuestro binomio que tenemos
que sumar también va a tener un término
en x cuadrada
y un término en x no sabemos cuáles son
sus términos sus elementos constantes
vamos a llamarles a esto
mi binomio misterioso a equis cuadrada
de equis y esto debe ser igual a este
resultado 5x cuadrada menos 6x vamos
primero agrupar los términos que tienen
la equis cuadrada estos de aquí será 3x
cuadrada más
x cuadrada mis términos con una sola x
menos 2 x más bx
- 2x más bx
que debe ser igual a el resultado 5x
cuadrada
es que es cuadrada menos 6 x
bueno sabemos que la suma de estos
términos con x cuadrada deberá ser igual
a este resultado de x cuadrada así que
podemos agrupar
es más a todo esto por equis cuadrada y
aquí a grupo esto que también sabemos
que esto el término con las equis deberá
ser igual a este resultado en la terminó
con la equis solita
será igual a podemos ponerlo de esta
manera más
-2 simplemente estoy intercambiando
estos dos elementos por equis igual a mi
resultado igual a 5x al cuadrado ahora
si lo tenemos agrupado bonito
pues podemos ver que este término
constante de las equis cuadradas deberá
ser este término constante en esta parte
así que lo voy a poner de este lado 3
más a debe de hacer igual a 5
este de acá debe de ser igual a este de
acá y por supuesto este término b -2
deberá ser igual a este menos 6 b menos
dos igual a menos seis resolvemos el de
aquí arriba restó tres en ambos lados de
la ecuación y me va a quedar que es
igual a 5 menos 32 y aquí abajo voy a
sumar 2 en ambos lados de esta ecuación
me va a quedar b es igual a menos 6 más
2 va a ser igual a menos 4 así que mi
binomio resultante de que me están
preguntando aquí va a ser igual
qué es 22 x al cuadrado b es menos
cuatro esto lo sustituyó menos 4x y este
es el resultado de lo que me preguntan
aquí la opción a veamos el siguiente
problema cuál de las siguientes
expresiones es igual a x + 2 más x menos
2 x 2 x + 1
tenemos que simplificar esto recuerden
que la multiplicación tiene prioridad
sobre la suma y la resta por lo que
tenemos que multiplicar lo que se
encuentra entre paréntesis vamos a
reescribir esto esta primera parte no se
modifican x + 2 que de igual
y ahora explicamos esto por esto
recuerden que cuando multiplicamos vino
no es simplemente usamos dos veces la
propiedad de distribución vamos a
distribuir este x 2 en ambos elementos
de este paréntesis de lo que está dentro
de este paréntesis mejor dicho así que
esto es más x menos 2 x 2 x bueno es x x
2 x
queda 2x al cuadrado
- 2 x 2 x va a ser menos 4 x
y ahora x 2 por 1 pues se va a conservar
así que va a ser más x menos 2
simplificando esto vamos a usar la
propiedad distributiva nuevamente y
ahora voy a agrupar los elementos que
tienen los mismos términos el elemento
al cuadrado nada más hay uno que esto
entonces va a ser igual a 2 x al
cuadrado vemos los elementos con la
equis aquí hay 1
aquí hay otro y aquí hay otro x menos 4
x menos 3 x mas x va a ser igual a menos
2x y finalmente nuestros términos
constantes que vemos aquí más 2 menos 2
pues al sumarlos nos va a dar 0 así que
nos queda este resultado que es la
opción a aunque de nuevo aquí no nos
estoy mostrando todas las opciones que
hay veamos el último problema nuestro
último problema dice una cancha de
voleibol tiene la forma de un rectángulo
tiene una altura de xy una base de 2 x
qué expresión da el área en metros y
aquí me estoy dando cuenta que se me
olvidó poner que la altura x está en
metros y la base también va a estar en
metros por eso es que nos piden el área
en metros bueno vamos a dibujar nuestra
cancha de voleibol
un rectángulo así que aquí vamos a
dibujarlo mas o menos así
sencillo sencillo
un rectángulo que uno de sus lados va
medir x
vamos a decir que este mide x que es el
más pequeño y el otro la base va a medir
2 x 2 x el doble de este otro lado
y nos preguntan el área bueno el área se
calcula con base x altura base vamos a
decir que esto es mi base 2x
multiplicada por la altura que es esta
x2 x mas x esto es igual a 2 x cuadrada
que es lo mismo que hago bien mi x
esto es lo mismo que 2 x x x x que es mi
opción b nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo